all right i want to start today with a
little data some numbers one often
repeated claim about gun violence in the
united states is
the gun violence is a problem in
so-called democrat cities
with the strictest gun laws in the
country and there's sort of two claims
that the right loves to make that are
implicit in that one the problems with
gun violence are in places that try to
restrict guns meaning restrictive gun
laws increase
violence and murder
and the second claim is
the most violent places are the places
run by democrats
i put together data in a few different
ways and we're going to look at it but
the most important i mean before even
looking at the data one of the things
you have to remember is that in general
there is more crime in more densely
populated areas the more densely
populated areas
tend to be places where people on the
left tend to live
but the truth is that the more violent
cities and the least violent cities are
all mostly run by democrats because
democrats prefer to live in cities
whereas republicans prefer to live in
rural areas generally speaking so
one of the things you first have to
think about is
what does the country look like before
we even can make any causal uh
claims
but that being said
let's take a look at some of this data
so what i did was i took the
where am i here i took the here we go
i took the most uh the 65
um cities with the highest murder rates
in the country and that's along the left
and you can find this data and uh those
are the cities that i have listed and
then we looked at who is the mayor of
those cities and are they a democrat or
a republican and then at the county
level was that a biden county or a trump
county in 2020 and then at the state
level was that a trump state or a biden
state in 2020. now i have to tell you
even doing this is a little fraught
because there are certain states
virginia a bunch of these cities are in
virginia in 2020 biden won but sometimes
republicans win virginia so some of
these states are question marks ohio is
a state that sometimes flips florida is
a state that sometimes slips but there's
a trend here that is very clear
the
cities with the most uh the highest
murder rates
at the city level it's mostly democratic
mayors now we would expect that that
makes perfect sense cities tend to be
run by democrats if we looked at a list
of the cities with the least gun
violence you would also see that they're
mostly run by democrats
cities often make up the entire county
in which they are or close to it in new
york city actually there's
the city includes multiple counties uh
brooklyn's and kings county whereas
manhattan okay we some people sort of
understand that but generally speaking
you would assume that the county would
be similar to the city in that
cities and counties often are the same
size or very close to it and most of the
counties that contain these cities were
biden counties well is that a big
revelation about gun violence not really
because if you look at the entire map of
the united states
by county we know that cities tend to
vote for democrats and all the other
counties tend to vote for republicans
typically so
cities on the most dangerous list and
cities on the least dangerous list would
all be um on the
uh
on would be run by would be democratic
counties and then lastly you look at the
state level and when you look at the
state level you see that there's a lot
of red there a lot a lot a lot of red
trump
states that trump won
and when we want to draw a causal
relationship one of the questions we
have to ask
is whether gun policy tends to be set at
the city county or state level
and it's mostly at the state level so
if we understand
most of the murders will be where there
is more population density
but the gun laws are mostly going to be
set at the state level
you have to ask well does saint louis
have a lot of murders because the mayor
is a democrat
or because it's a red state with red
state gun laws i'm not pretending that
the answer in all cases is one or the
other
but if we understand
that it's mostly states that determine
gun policy although there are some
cities that will go above and beyond
that's absolutely the case and we
understand that at the base rate
democrats tend to live more in cities
than republicans and we understand that
even if you're in chicago chicago's gun
laws if you can drive into indiana at
the end of the day
don't really impact your ability to get
a gun very much unless there's a
cohesive effort
this repeated talking point of gun
violence is a democrat city problem
very quickly falls apart now i'm totally
open
to exploring other explanations let me
give you another one
we can also accurately say gun violence
seems to be a red state problem
but there as well i'm willing to say
maybe access to mental health is part of
it we've got to deal with the guns but
maybe mental health is part of it but
it's the red states that fund mental
health services less than blue states we
looked at that earlier this week it's
the red states like texas that have
governors like greg abbott who recently
voted against more funding for mental
health treatment so
i say let's look at all of these things
but we have to include guns in that and
we have to understand
democrat city problem
is not accurate and there's no
particular reason to look at cities
rather than states when you look at
states it's a red state problem
if you look at cities it's a democrat
problem only in the sense that most
cities are run by democrats the really
safe ones and the unsafe ones so i think
you get the picture we're going to
continue following up on this
one of our sponsors is crush organics
these guys are awesome they support the
show they have an excellent collection
of premium grade organic cbd products
crush organics has your oils your
topical creams gummies they even have
these great experience gift boxes which
are great for sending to someone this is
the one i received really beautifully
packaged crush has a daytime cbd blend
in peppermint as well as a nighttime
blend lots of people report cbd being
helpful for sleep crush's cbd topical
cream can be used on joints and muscles
definitely try the gummies too those are
great some people prefer the gummies
over the oils crush organics care a lot
about quality so you can feel good about
getting your cbd from them they're
always dropping new products pay
attention to the site and crush organics
are fans of the david pakman show just
like you i hope so they're giving you a
massive discount forty percent off all
products go to crush organics dot us and
use the code pacman to save 40
the link is down below